what the country needs at this time is
clarity and reassurance and at the
moment both are in pretty short supply
and at the heart of the problem it seems
is the Prime Minister made a statement
last night before the plan was written
or at least finalized and that has
caused considerable confusion so
yesterday afternoon there was a
number-10 press release that said from
Monday a today anyone who can't work
from home for instance those in
construction and manufacturing should be
actively encouraged to go to work so
it's understood from that that it was
today was the start day and that was for
construction of manufacturing a few
hours later the prime minister made his
statement there was no express reference
to time frame today in the command
document page 25 it says that these
policy changes apply from Wednesday and
the list has been expanded from
construction of manufacturing to other
sectors so now we have a start date of
Wednesday and a wider range of sectors
that are going back to work on Wednesday
so far so good one of the key issues
then is will the Beeb guidelines in
place to ensure safety at the workforce
they were being consulted on last Sunday
they were vague and had big gaps in so
under protective equipment it just said
to be inserted or to be added in the
document I've now seen it says that
workplaces should follow the code of
secure guidelines which I assume the
same guidelines as soon as practicable
but under page 22 22 it says they will
be released later this week so we know
we're going some people go back to work
on Wednesday the guidelines have not
been published their parent lis going to
be released later this week so can I
just ask the Prime Minister will the
guidelines the safety guidelines be
ready for Wednesday which realistically
means tomorrow if workplace it could be
ready for them for Wednesday morning if
not is he seriously asking people to go
back to work without the guidelines have
the guidelines now being agreed with
businesses and trade unions that was the
attempt that was going on Sunday week
ago and to the guidelines only apply in
England